k bon alors tu es ya quelques jours je
vous présentais c'est celui là c'est le
nouveau samsung galaxy à 52 il est très
intéressant et c'est le produit qui a
priori en 2021 devrait le plus se vante
pour ça le souffle sais pas si vous
connaissez bien la gamme de samsung vous
avez la gamma qui va regrouper l'entrée
et le milieu de gamme et après la
guinness qui est plus sur le haut de
gamme photo vidéo il ya la gamme note
sur la productivité avec le stylet et
puis vous avez tous qui se plie avec les
zz folz et flipper compagnie la gamme
avec le à 50 dos et le modèle de masse
le modèle qui va se vend le plus
pourquoi pas déjà parce que les
précédents à 51 élus à 57 et les modèles
peut plus fonctionner même si samsung ne
vous le dis pas directement mais c'était
la goutte d'alcool et plus fonctionner
et là avec ce samsung galaxy à 50,2
samsung risque de cartonner une fois de
plus longtemps la question c'est est-ce
que ça venait vraiment intéressant ce
que c'est vraiment un modèle qui vous
faut il ya une offre qui est énorme dans
ce segment de prix là ils coûtent tous
noté la rade et la noirceur blanc il dit
ajouté ça comme ça 449 euros ça c'est
sur le modèle 5 g il existe un modèle
qui n'est pas du tout 5 g qui est 4g
alors le modèle 5 g c'est un modèle que
vous allez acheter par votre opérateur
la plupart du temps pourquoi parce que
les opérateurs vont venir pousser les
offres 5g pour vous vendre des
abonnements 5 g mais si vous voulez
l'acheter nu vous pouvez l'acheter nu à
449 euros alors là ce smartphone il est
super intéressant plat sur plein de
points mais vraiment vraiment donc je
vais tous vous détailler et il a aussi
quelques petites faiblesses par rapport
à ce qu'on peut trouver sur le marché à
la concurrence je vous détailler tout ça
je vous expliquais vous dire si au final
ce samsung galaxy à 52 5 g est
intéressant plus ou pas du tout et une
fois de plus et il faut le savoir le
modèle qui est 4g est en dessous des 400
euros donc si c'est une question de
budget le modèle 4g bien mais vous
n'aurez pas de 5g tout en sachant que
lorsque vous venez acheter un smartphone
aujourd'hui début 2000 21 ans mi-2000
matin avoir fin 2021
et bien vous allez regarder deux trois
ans donc ça vous emmène quand même
jusqu'à 2023/2024 voire un peu plus si
affinités que ça veut donc dire que si
vous pensez switcher à la 5g dans
quelques temps eh bien peut-être vaut-il
mettre dès maintenant un peu plus de
budget dans la mesure où c'est possible
pour acheter un smartphone compatible 5
g
[Musique]
c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est
réalisé en partenariat des cris bosh il
parce qu'avoir un très beau smartphone
c'est bien mais c'est encore mieux de
venir le protéger avec une coque en tout
cas une protection et ici chez rhino
chine des protections ghana des tonnes
an à partir de cette coque là vous la
prenez vous mettez dedans
il vient vous le protéger tous les côtés
ça c'est vraiment super et ça marche
merveilleusement bien et vous avez plein
d'autres cordes en plein d'univers
différence de l'avs et pour tous les
goûts alors si vous aimez plus de sport
et bien vous avez la nba notamment ici
les chicago bulls
vous avez également des causes qui sont
approuvés par la nasa est super sympa
irait dans tous les univers on va voir
du interrupteur on va avoir du fort cnai
de tous les côtés on va même avoir
assassiné chaîne classroom on va trouver
également fairy terre il y en a vraiment
pour tout le monde et même des jolie
coque en carbone et si vous voulez voir
le dos de votre smartphone eh bien vous
avez de la crasse garde du mode enix
complètement personnalisable
customisation pourrait venir ensuite si
vous souhaitez ajouter des protections
pour le dos de votre smartphone dans
différents univers que sont league of
legends compagnie et il y en a pour tout
le monde donc ça s'est super bien comme
aime venir protéger également l'écran de
votre smartphone avec notamment les
impacts screen protector vous invite à
cliquer sur le lien présent en bas dans
la description vous avez déjà un code de
remise pour acheter vos produits moins
chers chez rhino chine et ça s'est super
bien et en plus vous découvrirez plein
de produits pour venir protéger
notamment entre autres votre samsung
galaxy à 52 et ça c'est très cool
première chose que je viens des messies
brasser le design d'alors bien que vous
aviez un dos en plastique et qu'on n'est
pas forcément ici le plus bel effet
premium et bien malgré tout se doit en
plastique il fonctionne bien et j'aime
bien l'idée de l'intégration niveau de
la caméra là je trouve ça super sympa
que vous retrouviez les mêmes codes
couleurs alors il existe d'autres
couleurs je vous ai présenté notamment
un modèle bleu il ya un modèle l'avant
sur le modèle noir ça marche très bien
aussi c'est un grand classique c'est une
fois de plus france le modèle noir qui
fonctionnera le mieux mais pour trois
ans
cette cohérence au niveau de la couleur
entre le dos entre la partie photo doc
se donne le d'esthétique est vraiment
sympa on voit un que c'est du plastique
le plastique est malgré tout quand même
assez robuste donc ça fonctionnera bien
j'aime bien le design aussi avec l'écran
lors les crans à l'écran infiniti au
kiel et verrouille bien finie tio
pourquoi parce que vous avez ce petit
trou ici en fait c'est vraiment pour
s'amuser s'est tapé là sont là on va
retrouver un petit menton mais qui est
pas énorme non plus a prise en main est
vraiment bon on est serein
ratio vingt neuvième donc quand même
relativement allongée donc en termes de
confort de prise en main de visionnage
pour moi c'est vraiment un super bon
produit le capteur d'empreinte digitale
est positionné ici déverrouille bien et
assez rapide ça fonctionne bien mon
après d'un point de vue esthétique j'ai
pas grand chose de plus à dire vous
raconter je vous l'avais déjà présenté
ce qui va déjà me plaire c'est juste ma
femme qui est pas très lourd qui fait
189 g donc en termes de poids de confort
c'est pareil lorsque vous je vois déjà
vous le tenez vous regardez en fait vous
n'êtes pas embêtés par le poids donc ça
c'est bien ce qui viendra sur eux c'est
qu'en plus j'ai un verre corning gorilla
glass 5 à l'avant donc résistance et pas
la dernière génération née quand même
suffisamment résistant donc ça sera
aussi intéressant et surtout un des très
gros point fort de ce smartphone c'est
son écran vous avez une dalle de 6,5
pouces 6,5 pouces et quand même et non
on est sur du super amoled convard qu'on
est à 449 euros chez samsung on reste
sur une dalle super amoled très très
belle qualité extrêmement bien calibré
de la part de samsung
si vous venez un petit peu trifouiller
dans vos réglages et dans le mode de
l'écran des envies vif c'est par défaut
vous pouvez switcher en naturel ça va
venir casser un peu côté saturé pourra
me retrouver ici personnellement vives
pour moi ça fonctionne bien peu via un
module est un peu la balance des blancs
si vous souhaitez le réchauffer un peu
pourquoi pas mais tu es ajuste la la
comme ça la voyez ça pour moi vous avez
un super bon compromis c'est hyper
reposant c'est agréable il ya un confort
pour les yeux tout en sachant qu'ici en
pleine ville sur un écran qui est
certifié lutter contre la lumière bleue
on est de résolution full hd + ça
fonctionnera bien on va pas se rendre à
voir plus sur un smartphone à 449 euros
après il ya un autre truc est tout
nouveau cette année
si au niveau du haut parleur vous avez
des hauts parleurs stéréo c'est vraiment
un nouveauté parce que jusqu'à présent
que vous aviez des hauts parleur mono ça
ajoute un petit peu plus forcément en
immersion ça ajoute à l'expérience sans
pour autant être complètement
révolutionnaire
je voulus de suite le premier truc qu'il
faut savoir c'est un certain
déséquilibre mais c'est normal c'est
vraiment normal dans cette gamme de prix
pourquoi sur votre haut parleurs qui
situe sur la tranche le son sort sur le
côté c'est à dire le son il part par là
il s'en va par là celui là qui est juste
planqué ici il est plus dans cette
directive itella ce qui fait qu'en fait
vous avez vraiment du son qui part comme
ça du son qui part comme ça donc on
n'est pas sur une expérience d'écouté
comme ça en tout cas avec les haut
parleurs parfaite c'est sûr mais par
contre je trouve que samsung a
extrêmement bien bossé pour moi qu'on
est sûrs en un smartphone à 449 euros
l'expérience audio kamel bien maîtrisé
vous avez un son qui est hyper claire
hyperclean alors on reste sur le médium
d'autant plus si vous pousser à fond et
bien évidemment on va pas se tendent à
avoir des grosses bases qui ronronne
mais l'expérience est très très cool et
ça apporte en immersion longtemps tout
ce qui va être usages multimédias pour
me regarder des films des séries pour
des jetons le gaming on va y venir dans
quelques instants
et bien l'expérience elle est super
bonne donc ça s'est vraiment bien alors
après si vous le souhaitez ce que je
vous conseille quand même pour aller
beaucoup plus loin c'est devenir branché
ici un petit petit casque l'emprise déjà
que je pouvais le faire dans ces
segments de prix aussi on retrouve
énormément moins dans le haut de gamme -
dans le premium mais dans le milieu de
gamme entrée de gamme vous retrouvez des
petites prises jack
d'autant plus qu'ici vous avez du
bluetooth 5.0 il ya du doigt le biathlon
zouk l'expérience globale au niveau
audio
elle est augmenté par rapport aux autres
modèles que l'était le a50 et le a50
donc le à 52 pour ça il ya vraiment une
très très belle carte à jouer là dessus
alors là où je vais trouver un petit peu
moins bon et un peu moins performant par
rapport aux autres modèles
c'est sûr justement la performance ici
vous avez un qualcomm snapdragon 750 g
sur le modèle 5 g sur le modèle 4g vous
êtes sur un 720 j'ai bon alors éviter de
passer un peu le ces chiffres un peu
barbare je les trouve très bien
franchement ils marchent bien de faire
tourner beaucoup de jeu du pl ace sort
pour venir vous amuser à tout ce que
vous voulez mais vous voyez dans ce
segment prix à 440 euros je m'attendrais
à voir ce qui ce fait ils vont trouver
la concurrence destin dragon 7 165 g qui
seront plus performants que le
snapdragon 750 g alors ça se joue à pas
grand-chose mais malgré tout vous avez
une différence et quand je suis
consommateur est bien cette différence
allait importants ponts d'un autre côté
s'ils vont regarder sur le les
concurrents sur le reste du marché vous
n'allez pas forcément avoir cette
qualité au niveau de l'écran vous
n'allez pas forcément avoir tous détails
d'autant plus que si au niveau de
l'écran et je voulais pas du taux de
rafraîchissement 120 hertz pour le game
is pharma
super bien en plus on confie vous avez
si giga de ram 128 go de stockage
extensible jusqu'à un téraoctet ça
fracasse et très standard la batterie
c'est aussi très standard 4500 millions
paire d'heures on peut retrouver des
plus grosses batteries dans cette gamme
de prix bon ok pourquoi pas dès 4500
dira très bien alors certes interne on
sait que samsung nous dit vous avez de
la recharge rapide il est compatible
cherchera plus en tout cas 25 watts mais
nous on vous met un chargeur uniquement
dans la boîte de 15 watts
bon ça fait un petit peu râler parce que
15 watts il va falloir prendre un peu
plus votre mal en patience fatalement
quand 25 watts médiathèque ce qui est
mieux pour la batterie du smartphone
sans surcharger le lancement dont vous
le recharger en 15 watts ça veut dire
préserver en réalité l'intégrité des
cellules de la batterie de votre
smartphone pour l'heure mais beaucoup
plus loin ce que je vous conseille
vraiment ce que je vous recommande ce et
de leurs charges et quand ils arrivent à
20 ans en est quand il à 80% vous le
débrancher vous êtes repartis vous de
journée une journée une journée mais
pensez alors recharger le soir vous
embêtez pas à leur charge et la journée
vous allez mettre plus d'une heure une
heure une heure trente pour de recharge
et de 0 à 100% ça sert à rien ne
recherchait de 0 à 100% chargé le de 20
à 80 % vous gagnerez du temps vous
gagnera en efficacité
ça sera mieux pour la durée de vie de la
batterie de votre smartphone donc
l'autonomie elle est quand même plutôt
par beauvais ça va dépendre de vous et
de vos yeux le temps il ya tout qui est
un peu moins bon niveau de l'autonomie
et bien c'est qu'ici vous n'avez pas un
taux de rafraîchissement adaptatif je
vous explique ce que vous allez
retrouver avec des smartphones plus haut
de gamme chez samsung c'est à dire que
lorsque vous êtes en 120 hertz et bien
lui lorsque vous utilisez pas du sang
manière telle à switcher entre 2,90 hier
60 hertz voir un peu en dessous sur
notamment due aux noix zone display ici
c'est pas possible
vous allez choisir la fluidité des
mouvement c'est-à-dire 120 hertz tout le
temps tout le temps ou alors 60 hertz
tout temps tout le temps le problème
c'est que 120 hertz tout le temps tout
le temps tout le temps ça va venir
consommer davantage
mais on va pas nécessairement non plus a
lancé par amel tout le temps maintien je
suis pas sûr que je me sois sûr santerre
tiens je vais naviguer sur les réseaux
sociaux
je switche 120 hertz vous allez être 120
et aston qu'il va falloir accepter que
votre autonomie va être un peu moins
bonne parce que vous n'êtes pas sûrs du
120 hertz adaptatif après l'autre point
qui est intéressant il ya des gros
usagers toute la partie photo alors si
vous regardez bien la partie photo ici à
l'arrière voyez vous avez quatre
capteurs quatre capteurs en réalité vous
avez un vrai capteurs qui intéresse en
un an et demi regardez le jour montrent
vous allez retrouver tout temps aussi
c'est un ultra grand angle en fait je
vous ai déjà présenté
si vous leur situé très rapidement c'est
un 12 mégapixels tous vos rêves 2.2 à 1
123 degrés en dessous si c'est votre
caméra principale 64 mégapixels et ouvre
à f 1.8
avec une stabilisation optique alors en
fait 64 mégapixels mais ils ont ce
qu'ils appelaient la technologie de
regrouper quatre pixels en inde on vous
a utilisé quatre pixels de vote 64
mégapixels pour nous sortir les couteaux
et une résolution plus basse mais avec
une meilleure luminosité et un
traitement logiciel d'ailleurs que la
fac que ça va être beaucoup plus sympas
à regarder
alors vous pouvez passer en 64
mégapixels si vous souhaitez bon je
pense qu'il vaut mieux laisser faire
l'algorithme est et l'ouest pour ça
fonctionne tout seul et ça ira très très
bien vous allez ensuite repassé en
dessous ici sur votre caméra portrait
c'est un 5 mégapixels touvre f 2.4
exactement la même chose ici c'est votre
caméra macro 5 mégapixels tourelles 2.4
je vous montre le résultat dans quelques
instants pour moi la macro ici pas trop
d'intérêt
le mode portrait pas trop d'intérêt
l'ultra grand angle on peut il faut
qu'il fasse beau qu'il vraiment de très
très belles conditions de luminosité et
le 64 pixels mis pas mal je vous montre
sa main tac aux attentes et à l'avant
vous retrouver ici et là des peuples à
l'époque est juste là votre caméra de
celle fils une 30 2 mégapixels
vous pouvez bien filmé c'est sur 4 k4
cahu hd à 30 images par seconde tout en
sachant que vous avez un mode super
stabiliser sa mode actionne calme en
quelque sorte qui va vraiment venir
compenser électroniquement la
stabilisation lorsque vous bougez le
temps déplacement pour avoir un truc un
peu plus fluide un peu plus mou de broc
et pourquoi pas samsung est très très
fort pour la photo très fort aussi pour
tout ce qui est vidéo ils ont le mode
single take qui est là ils ont un mode
amusant aussi qu'à ses rivaux dont
composé à quelques petits trucs si on le
souhaite avec des petits filtre on peut
se marrer on va commencer tout de suite
par la photo de nuit là on est sur
l'ultra grand temps et sur l'ultra grand
temps l'on voit quoi on voit du bruit on
voit de l'imprécision il n'y a aucune
stabilisation optique là dessus le
résultat n'est vraiment pas terrible sur
la caméra principale on sort des choses
pas mal l'algo via un petit peu tous
pousser de l'autre côté on n'est pas sur
un smartphone complètement dingos 440
euros à peu près donc il faut vraiment
le savoir
et lorsque vous venez vous rapprocher et
bien l'algorithme cherche à compenser
c'est vraiment pas terrible donc sur la
photo de nuit on peut sentir des
chaussures la caméra principale mais dès
qu'on va passer à ultra grand-angle vous
convient au nez c'est pas extraordinaire
il a un petit peu de mal sur les stands
et le bien mais une fois de plus on
n'est pas dans la série s de samsung
donc c'est normal complètement normal en
photo de celle fit également de nuit
voyez bon ben voilà c'est des choses
qu'on oubliera très très très rapidement
photo plein jour eh bien écoutez la
caméra principale est pas mal elle est
vraiment pas mal alors là y'avait pas
une lumière 20 mai
malgré tout on voit bien les nuages on
arrive bien à voir les différents cas
j'irai la scène devant on voit ce qui au
fond ça fonctionne dans la gestion de
lumière est pas mauvaise l'ultra
grand-angle freitag d'ailleurs vous avez
effectivement et bien de la lumière on
va perdre une fois de plus sans
précision sur les côtés mais ça c'est
pas anormal vu l'optique on peut venir
zoomer en x 2 mai éviter le faux dit ça
parce que vraiment le résultat n'est pas
du tout à la hauteur caméra participe
pas être plus ça fonctionne les couleurs
sont la cp temps c'est du samsung ça
marche l'ultra grand temps que c'est pas
pareil à la colorimétrie vraiment
vraiment différente fois de hockey il
faut dix n'en voyez c'est vraiment
vraiment la même chose qu'eux qui va
venir se répliquer tout au long sur les
différentes photos vous allez voir c'est
vraiment le constate en tout cas que je
vais venir sortir ici sur la caméra
principale c'est pas mal mais le reste
c'est vraiment beaucoup plus accessoire
la macro une fois de plus c'est pas d'un
go ça marche pas très bien on a beaucoup
de mal à venir retrouver la bonne
position il n'y a aucune stabilisation
est avec moi ça ne pardonne absolument
pas donc on y arrive on est au plat une
fois de temps en temps à trouver un truc
pas trop mal mais même quand c'est pas
trop mal c'est pas suffisamment bien la
caméra de portraits fonctionne pas trop
trop trop trop mal elle a un peu de mal
dès lors que c'est un poil plus complexe
on le voit ici au niveau des cheveux la
caméra de celle filles et pas trop trop
mal et paumé venir élargir l'assiette
pour des rentrées permis de rentrer vos
amis dans le cadre si vous le souhaitez
jacques le point un peu négatif que
j'aime bien vous montrer si c'est la
question du très grand-angle
on a des petits bouts de doigts qui
dépasse à droite à gauche c'est assez
difficile de trouver la bonne position à
cause de la position du module photo
mais sinon dans l'ensemble ça va quand
même pas trop trop mal ce qui est aussi
intéressant c'est que c'est un
smartphone qui est résistant à l'eau et
à la poussière de la certification ip67
dont quelque part c'est aussi rassurant
même si les générations précédentes ne
craignait pas pour autant l'eau alors là
vous avez fabien l'immerger vous amuser
c'est pas le but mais s'il pleut vous
êtes tranquille si vous renversez de
l'eau par hasard dessus vous êtes
tranquille et c'est rassurant vous avez
en plus ce qu'ils font en termes de
collectivités mais sur du wifi 6 du nfc
pour le paiement dématérialisé notamment
avec son père ou google paye et vous
avez un indice de réparabilité de 8
e sur 10 ce que je veux aussi beaucoup
aimé est ce que je vous recommande
vraiment est ce qui fait la différence
est là où ce smartphone sera unique
c'est toute l'expérience logiciel vous
avez one ua et l'onu maïs est super bien
c'est bien organiser vos années votre
votre tiroir d'application vont trouver
ça très facilement vous êtes tous vos
paramètres sur le haut qui sont très
faciles d'accès toute cette partie
paramètres aussi supra cool que vous
retrouvez très très très facilement
c'est bien organisé c'est logique très
très bien fait plein de petits
raccourcis vous voulez arriver par
exemple au mode wifi et bien vous
laisser appuyé sitac vous arrivez mode
wifi enfin one nuage c'est bien fait
c'est bien pensé c'est malin c'est
intelligent au sein des très très gros
point fort ici chez samsung et sisteron
ubaye 3.1 basé sur l'android 11 vous
avez 3 ans mise à jour android et quatre
ans de mise à jour de sécurité pendant
les très gros point fort de ce
smartphone c'est cet écran qui est super
bien calibré 120 hertz
même si effectivement on n'est pas sûr
l'adaptative mais bon 450 euros peut pas
non plus demander la lune les haut
parleurs stéréo sont très bien pour
l'expérience multimédia l'expérience de
gaming c'est très cool d'avoir une prise
jack c'est bien j'aime beaucoup
l'expérience logiciel qui est un très
très gros point fort l'autonomie est
correcte
j'aime beaucoup ce look aussi que je
trouve super bien réussi un design qui
est vraiment dans l'air du temps en tout
cas à 2020 donc ça ça fonctionne très
bien
la partie photo sur la caméra principale
j'aime beaucoup et ça marche bien il va
pas être le plus dingue de tous les
smartphones de ce segment de prix en
termes de performances néanmoins il n'a
pas à rougir il vous propose de très
honnêtes qui marchera très bien et je
pense que ce smartphone là il va
vraiment cartonné d'ailleurs dit marc
vous ce que vous en pensez ce que vous
avez déjà acheté un smartphone de
samsung galaxy à 58 à 51 pourquoi pas la
dernière
et est ce que ce à 50 de change il va
vous intéresser
ou pas d'ailleurs dit que le mois en bas
en commentaire ce qui est sûr c'est que
si vous voulez vous faire plaisir avec
un très beau smartphone de samsung et
vous allez le budget 449 euros et vous
voulez de la 5g vous pouvez y aller les
yeux fermés
sur ce je vous embrasse moi beaucoup
d'amour de gros bisous pour les soirées
vous et à très bientôt
charles kao